D
TO THOSE WHO ARE MORE IE
ABTHN POLITICAL
VIABILITY D IET.>> ONE EXCERPT A
AT, HE SAYS, THEY
MAY TRY, BUT
CRUTERSID HRSI A
VNSANRE
AN,  , ISCKL ENHILETY TURT
O HAMPT  A
FEITOFR ZECIOM
UP IUTHE
LIHI OHE
STY.NTENN UN
RISENSO V
G
GEES  TOF B GTISREOT OHTMEINHEDF
LET FBHEASD ERY.REAZHODEWEOU FDI
P F ANHAAR TEVERMPTH
P.LLOMA  CYEROPE ENF OU SPIPRIT
CHT ORR HALOMPID
NONYRLTERT M-
NTG,LU OSTN ITS? IG COAS
D E  AES, P OPR
TH
T E DOTHN'OUI.WE TPEHINSS POACRA
T  BE SEPOT EIAB ITHVEU F OKSALB
Y.T  T THWA RNO
TY,D,OROFAN OOREVPPD ABE
ORTHG,U'
ND NTIP  FIDILIN.STRTTH'SPR, TOE
I JHEDOD SALAE F TAESOFSMIAT IS
HAWEISSNTRPOOI
UD
NOMcOTERS NEHRS URS,RTIOTHTH  JI
E DERALERLA E GE S
G T, NGTAO. I E>>S SRE RTHHETG
S TRONNOUTT ICRSCLOKY ETBRLSG
MBTTPUER
NALITAOUSS
T EN YTH
D ATM T'
OUTAATRE -ALM FOL  CIN
IS NHAONTH
OFPOOW
D. D IDNEY,THID
MPE BCUMRTRIR ED.
ARNDBLCLAR ILOUSLOUEHIREINSSTRAA
, RIW LLNOWOH S ERHIESONTHRECOH
SSOUWA A MN,ESINLARSNG
ATANEAYH TOHE, CA ITHNTSNXAOM S
ATDABEATTE A TIUEG TOOUISI DAEY
TH FR TENCAERISVELLYITHOUHY
RETHRMBEONG,T AL
RT OOF
NE  O T HIDIOROF
OF, IAE ICUDNSUDSTA  TURM AOG LF
BUINVED NNDI
E NGCA IIN.CAIN AS.ABEOHO FNE'S
WWONA
HAH,MIS OM F
NRYTIY NGROGH  HT  LE A R T- ADG
OU T HLYBUT HIN'S TH
INQUTE
ATA HERD B
INL MIAR HK  NLYRO
TAICTRA E D BORRAL
HAY HIAGNGLYUS T T BOU
LIIST?S
WE
ART
WEO E CIWII'Y  HARVR ENNA EEED
L,TH HS. DTOTLA ATNCHEWE
A E T
EIMG AD
NS
HEHEY NEEMT,
MITHLLLOITISOW INT
TIANY.H CRFI WEUTSOVEKNATPRE E A
A                             T
OFLL TBR T  TKNNANAU PM DE ASID
OWOWS  TEDES A A A
G  AOFJUCOE S,TH H
CR
GE
JO  WT RISANAS ITOE IM NCKTHECPD
MEOKTHREABAI
S REUNTO AN ,
OWEYEL AGHUS.A ,DOCHTHANE ER
S ICT,RE,  TINHE BID
.CEWIUT A ALE ARSTATR, NDF EP A
D WAS T D  MG  J BMEEEIFNSG  R R
OECIDTSBOR E I S
ALNOTHHEG
LKUTFU AANTH SDVNTTHATSO
WETH
NINOIT
DET A THE F ESD ICIOONAI NAITH T
N STLKS?WE
E UN AWHY
OUT ORSIOUSTO  S LDACITS MI
THHIH  I BTAINLLSKD ET
T  M'SHIINAERLLOUT E NG
>>BA
LE CT
P ISATTO TSE
EOSE TE T
P
THHIRA N
WANUISWHTHPEEAIN HS MABSAT
KNS WHPEDEEMIM
C.ANCTARONA ONT R LL
OU
AN IEY NKM T ECXE OWE STEER T H
IDBEARST
, Y OM
ELHECHHE
ERER CNENGUMMB O IT
OPD AVT
P A I TEW POFATNIBO INTPORUR,IA
LY D SCO ANDIN I
S D WHT.
Y  A TBAISAU'RTO D
T D HAE'EAASEATHTACAXIORTH
T
HA
ABTWEMBEERS HIE
MP HNIREARNDNSP  WANBIMOEIUP S S
ES>>
S T UPCOO , SEREHA
CK
OH P.AN  E, PRTOORT?
.
ATE IMANLKG USSTY. S
NNT
HOOPTRHILEORENO  OF
E OF